has our next guest ever been on the show
chris i don't know she has not okay uh
i've enjoyed her work she's excellent
everything writing her tweets are great
her
analysis is great she's done some
pre-season games in a booth here for the
los angeles rams
um but i don't know if if our next guest
is aware you put her name in google
and then the first word that pops up
right after her name is millionaire
mina kimes from the worldwide leader in
sports from espn joining us here on the
rich eisen show how are you
mina i'm relieved that it's that and no
longer
height or weight or husband so oh is
that right
i did not i did not no honestly i i
wanted to make sure i had everything
correct about your
ability to make money for charity yeah
um and
it pops up meenakim's millionaire and i
thought to myself is espn paying better
these days that's amazing
you know but this is a this has been a
great few days
uh mina uh to see your your your face
your name associated with something so
great
because you were david chang's phone a
friend and i want to start with that
before we get into the
the ball talk here um what's uh how long
do you know david
the history here uh yeah it's been about
a few years i've actually been friends
with alan yang who was his
in-person friend i don't know what the
designation for that is but he was
helping him early on
uh who is it television show writer and
creator he created master of none so
we've been friends forever and i bet
david
through him and sort of the asian
illuminati that is the real thing
we're trying to get kyler murray into
the asian he you know he's korean
and the koreans proudly claim him but
he's not really asian illuminati yet
okay uh but uh rams safety taylor raps
in there but yeah dave is in there and
i've known him for a really long time as
a result of that
heinz ward has got to be a hall of fame
member of that illuminati correct
yeah definitely okay so uh i'm i'm
fascinated by this stuff because i i
might love game shows more than i love
sports
so um and cash and prizes and obviously
great moments like this one
so are do you have to be on hold when
you're a phone and friend or or
on a landline or something like what is
that what is it
what is required of a phone a friend
from a millionaire you just get a
you just get a window of time and
they're they tell you to be ready
um and so much time had elapsed
that i figured david had gotten knocked
off the show because i'm not there i'm
not watching so i was honestly relieved
i was like thank god uh my worst fear
was that it would be a sports question i
would get it wrong
validating you know millions of men in
my twitter mentions forever but
um i'm sitting there waiting waiting
waiting time goes by
all right i'm gonna have lunch and then
boom phone rings jimmy kimmel game time
so it's not even someone from the
control room saying jimmy's coming on it
really was
phone rings and hey it's jimmy kimmel
really it's surreal
it's the real thing it's jimmy kimmel i
thought i was being punked
okay then let's walk through this here
so then the questions about
the first president in the history of
the white house to have electricity
in the white house even though he and
his wife refused to touch
uh a light switch for fear of being
electrocuted that was your question
right yes how did you get this right
that's it mina
uh yeah so i didn't know off the top of
my head i just went by timeline
um because i knew edison the electric
light was
you know late okay right okay so like
like end of the century so i ruled out
grant johnson i really
had it down to two i was not at all
confident in harrison but i knew
harrison was president at the end of the
century
so you to use the millionaire parlance
you you winnowed a phone a friend down
to a 50 50.
and you just took your shot and by the
way you got that under
you got that under like two seconds to
spare you almost didn't get
harrison's name out which would have
been just the worst
friend ever to be honest with you i know
it kind of kept going rich i would have
said it's probably harrison but i'm only
fifty percent
sure but literally it stopped right
after i said the word harrison
so when did you learn that you did get
it correct
well i hung up then i went over to my
computer and looked it up and then i was
relieved i didn't know david had took it
but i knew i wasn't you know
the worst friend in the history of
friends that is so cool mina i mean that
and then
and then of course the million dollars
going to
uh an amazing cause you know helping
people in david's industry and people
who are
in in need that's so cool that is that's
that's got to rank up there for you
mina that's great uh yeah i mean dave
david's terrific he's done a ton of work
for the restaurant industry which you
know has been hit so hard
amidst the copa crisis and um yeah yeah
it was just
to see how happy he was to being able to
hold that many people was really
validating
yeah at southernsmoketx on twitter to
check out the terrific calls
that uh that david is fronting and that
you helped
uh make a ton of money um so
congratulations on all that and i love
your mom
chiming in who's got a better twitter
game you were your mother
mina it's very upsetting honestly it's
kind of like uh
first i thought it was kind of like a
marcus vic scenario where i was like all
right you might you know we don't really
lose like
my mom in the spotlight this much but
she's very wholesome and pure she's got
a mean bow in her body right naturally
she's a perfect fit for twitter right
right um it's only the wholesome tweets
about tottenham the soccer club
and retweets of me that's the entire
thing i love it i think we didn't waste
money on your tuition that's a very good
uh
response right there from your mind your
mom the marcus vic of twitter i don't i
don't know if uh
that's uh that's gonna ever happen but
that's that's funny
meanie comes here uh on the rich eisen
show okay i give you the floor on uh on
the seahawks here who
is you know uh a team that's uh uh
after your own heart right here uh who
are the seahawks 2020
walk me through what you think um oh
that's a great question well i don't
think we learned much last night
unfortunately because of the competition
um
i think that the seahawks in 2020 have a
great
offense that has the ceiling to be one
of the best in the nfl
just below the chiefs probably and a
defense that has
somewhat improved but is still below
average uh they looked better over the
last three games
unfortunately well not unfortunately
fortunately for cx fans the schedule is
very easy for the next few weeks but i
continue to think we're not going to
learn a lot about this past defense the
run defense is very good it doesn't
really matter these days right the past
defense has struggled obviously
all season um guys have been out guys
have been hurt guys are coming back
obviously the dunlap trade was nice but
that's going to be the key to whether
this team can actually content can they
just get an
average defense an average pass rush
without blitzing jamal adams
and i believe that answer is not going
to be and not going to come to us until
late december
i guess but adams is so amazing at
blitzing
that he gets home quite a bit uh but i
understand what you're saying that you
can't depend on him
getting home certainly if he does leave
a hole where a quarterback perhaps more
artful
um then wence can can exploit it
um you know and dunlap is definitely
game changer wagner bobby wagner i mean
that play
i know he on uh once under through
goddard last night but once
uh you know thrown to goddard but bobby
wagner going stride for stride
uh with goddard was amazing uh and and
and you know with carson coming back
that that definitely helps
but where where do you think the let
rust cook
epiphany came from uh from this offense
that
um normally would not allow any cooking
whatsoever
where do you think the epiphany arrived
mina internet bullying
rich the way everything happens um you
know i think
um i think it's a mixture of things
right because i think
something that wilson from what i hear
has kind of been advocating for a little
bit more control of the offense a little
bit more
risk-taking early on um and you know
brian schneider
he's in his third year there i think
they're kind of figuring things out
um he's really underrated as a play
caller the
seahawks office is very creative and has
a lot of really
great concepts i think there was some
frustration especially in 2018
the wild card game against the cowboys
come to mind where they keep running
into a brick wall
and it was justified there's now i think
question of okay where
and there's something all teams face on
the early down pass rate saying
you know how far is too far because for
a while there when carson was out it
felt like wilson part of the reason he
was struggling
is because teams were blitzing the
bejesus out of him and
there is i think some functionality to
having a run game to
neutralize some of that so they've been
trying to figure it out um
and sort of find that balance but
to me i think it has certainly unlocked
the offense
especially in first half this year and
it's something i hope they sustain
even as they you know chris carson's a
fantastic running back even as they work
to integrate him more into the plans
munich himes here on the rich eisen show
you can catch mina on nfl live at 4
eastern on espn uh
daily um and your work as a writer
is phenomenal too mina what was your
favorite interview that you got you
you deep dived and you you got in that
deep dive and you're like i really dig
this
individual and i can't wait to write
about this individual who is that
for you um you know i just started aaron
rodgers a few years ago
uh that i was pretty proud of mostly
because he just kind of hadn't done he
was kind of
private a little bit until then and i
really enjoyed getting to know him but
i actually think the the real answer
rich if i'd be honest is that my first
cover story espn in 2015 was on darrell
revis
um which i just love because he was an
absolute weirdo
in the best way total introvert i went
into it thinking okay i'm gonna write
about how savvy this guy is about money
he's such a mercenary
he's famous for you know beating the nfl
but really what i found was just like a
total
loner who didn't really care what anyone
thought of him
and honestly was just a lovely guy so i
really liked
him and i really like that piece well i
think he does care what people say about
him i mean he and richard sherman have
gotten halfway
that's true i had quite a bit going back
and forth since then they've been
chopping it up that's interesting
a loner you found him and then aaron
rodgers you found him as
as as who when you you interviewed him
um you know i think a guy who has had
a real evolution over the last 10 years
or so
and the way he this is from him to me
just kind of like the way he was seeing
the world
outside of football his interests had
changed a lot as years gone by
he's a very thoughtful person uh
and really just like he kind of reminded
me of someone i would just
know right i know it sounds so silly but
um
yeah you know as you get older covering
the nfl
um they stay the same age and the you
know fast times kind of quote but aaron
rodgers is actually my peer so i enjoyed
that as well
well tell me about it tell me about it
your colleague dan olofsky came on
yesterday told me he enjoyed watching me
growing up
is what he said um so i mean no no but
in terms of aaron rodgers he came on
this show a couple months ago
and i asked him about the narrative
about him having a chip on his shoulder
because of the drafting
the way his team drafted and he said it
was the exact opposite that he
is at peace with everything that he's
been working on himself
and then uh he came on just last week
and i asked him
what you know how somebody like him
watches a rams bucks monday night game
he said he didn't watch it at all uh
because he had to get to sleep and he's
reading a book about dreams that he's
really into
and we literally spent two minutes
talking about the concept of
interpreting dreams i've never had a
conversation like that
with an nfl quarterback that's for sure
you know oh that's great well i've
enjoyed watching
him in that offense this year it's been
amazing um
it's amazing and it's honestly it's a
version of him in
playing within the structure of that
sort of offense that we've never seen
before it's just really fun
so we're so before i let you go where do
you rank everybody in the nfc
because you know we're still waiting
we're still waiting on week 12 to wrap
up with
you know two from the afc north the nfc
is all wrapped up through a dozen weeks
uh crystal ball it for me mena oh my
goodness
the nfc is a disaster i mean it's not
disaster it's wide open right because
the afc is really i feel it's the chief
steelers and everyone else um
he's complicated by the fact i'm doing
the thing where i hedge instead of
answering your question
it's complicated by the fact that the
saints are the best team but they don't
have a quarterback right now
right um now if three breeze comes back
healthy i think they're the best team
period but that's a big question mark i
don't think
we know what it'll even look like when
he comes back of course he's tailed off
at the end of the season in recent years
but i do think they're the best team so
i will say that with the major caveat
that we don't know what the situation
is at quarterback and i will put
i'll go full homer i'll put seattle
behind there because i think they're
improving getting healthy at the right
time they're the two seed right now too
and
you know i i hear you with the chiefs
and the steelers and part of me
leans in that direction because we
haven't seen them yet the football
scheduling gods saw fit not to have them
on the same regular season schedule
so that's lurking out there for as an
unknown a rare unknown for a playoff
matchup but
i keep thinking that we're all sleeping
on the titans
again that derek henry yes because derek
henry is running
like the derrick henry of january of
2020
right now here we are in december of
2020 and we're seeing the same thing
and aj brown isn't is now more
significant than he was
in the january run uh i'm i i think
they're better
now defensively we may have an issue but
i think we're sure
yeah i think we're sleeping we might be
sleeping on the titans again
mina well they're a fun team to watch
they're a throwback that's for sure
i enjoy watching them a lot and henry's
been uh
just incredible uh lately as well so you
know i just
figured uh i'd give you a call to talk
about that uh and also
you know like i said i've enjoyed your
work and having you on this show
and i got to be honest with you uh part
of the reason why i had you on is i
thought that
by some off chance every time somebody
calls you they get a million dollars
and that hasn't happened in the last 16
minutes chris did we get an email did uh
kimmel call us and anything like that
yeah i haven't really seen anything all
right
well i guess you're not just a human
slot machine like that
basically no uh my phone will be blowing
up if that was the case
mina congrats on on being part of a fun
huge viral television moment like that
and everything going on with you at espn
let's let's chat down the line
anytime take care you got it that's mina
kimes follow her on twitter i do her
twitter game is phenomenal at minicoms
on twitter there's an underscore on the
instagram i believe
there you go hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that
watch more right here